Bodham Pujyami Dhamman Pujyami Sangham Pujyami
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa
Bodham Saranam Gacchami Dhammam Saranam Gacchami Sangam Saranam Gacchami Dutiyambhi Bodham Saranam Gacchami Dutiyambhi Dhammam Saranam Gacchami
Dukhiyampi Sangam Saranam Gacchami Thakiyampi Buddham Saranam Gacchami Thakiyampi Dhammam Saranam Gacchami Thakiyampi Sangam Saranam Gacchami
Anathipatha Vairamani Sikapadan Samadhi Ami Adhinadana Vairamani Sikapadan Samadhi Ami Kamesumi Cacana Vairamani Sikapadan
Samadhi Ami Musa Wada Vairamani Sikapada Samadhi Ami Sura Mereya Majapamadatana Vairamani Sikapada Samadhi Ami
Very good.
So we can begin with a standing meditation.
So make sure you feel balanced.
grounded.
And lifting yourself up through the top of the head, standing tall.
Spending a moment relaxing, relaxing the brow.
Pasando un momento relajándote, relajando el entrecejo.
Eyes lowered, unfocused.
Los ojos bajados, sin focalizar.
The jaw.
La mandíbula.
If there's tension there, just clench the jaw and then relax.
Si hay tensión en la mandíbula, muévela y entonces relajará.
The shoulders, give them a squeeze.
Los hombros.
Hands joined in front or by the side, doesn't matter.
Just whatever is comfortable.
So acknowledging the posture, the energised spine, lifting us up, everything else relaxed.
Bring your attention to the soles of your feet.
What can you feel there?
Lleva tu atención a la planta de tus pies.
¿Qué puedes sentir ahí?
Can you isolate the sensations of pressure?
¿Puedes aislar las sensaciones de presión?
Can you do that with sensations of warmth or coolness?
Puedes hacerlo con las sensaciones de calor o frío.
And there are those subtle sensations that tell you what you're standing on.
the hardness of wood, the softness, the sponginess of a carpet.
There are those sensations that indicate the surface on which you are standing, the hardness of the wood or the sponginess of a carpet.
Acknowledging how the sensations are constantly changing as the body rebalances itself.
Recognizing how the sensations are constantly changing as the body rebalances itself.
The body rebalances itself.
and acknowledge how these sensations arise, whether we want them to or not.
They are not under our direct control.
So taking our time, let's come up the body, see what we can feel.
Y tomándonos nuestro tiempo ve subiendo a lo largo del cuerpo, observa lo que sientes, lo que puedes sentir.
Both inside and outside.
Tanto en el interior como en el exterior.
And there are areas that seem to be void of any feeling.
and how there are areas that seem to be empty of any feeling.
When you get to the abdomen, can you feel the breath there?
Is there any tension in the area?
Can you feel the breath?
In the stomach area.
Just the natural breath.
Any tension?
Do you feel the breath in the chest?
Do you have a shallow breath?
Any tension?
Shoulders still relaxed.
The jaw.
The brow.
And when you get to the scalp scan it like you did the soles of your feet.
Now without moving your eyes, just become aware of what's outside you.
Colours and shapes in front of you.
Los colores y las formas enfrente de ti.
Any sounds.
Cualquier sonido.
The atmosphere of the room.
La atmósfera de la habitación.
presence of other people either in your home or your neighbors.
So your attention is entirely out there.
Now at the same time, bring in the in here.
Both the inside
and the outside.
So this is the bubble of our consciousness.
This is the world we are actually experiencing moment after moment.
Este es el mundo que estamos experimentando momento tras momento.
This is our universe.
Este es nuestro universo.
And we can't get out of it.
No podemos salir de él.
You can't get underneath it, over, over the top of it.
You're always in the middle of it.
No podemos ir por debajo de él, por encima de él, en su cima.
Siempre estamos en medio de él.
So we may as well relax, just relax into this present moment, wide awake.
Así es que puedes relajarte, completamente relajada.
El momento presente, despierta.
relaxing abiding in the present moment wide awake in this mode we can let go of ideas of achieving something
ideas de lograr algo.
That's the mode of doing, doing something now for some future result.
Ese es el modo de hacer, hacer algo ahora para algún resultado futuro.
But in this mode, just being, this is the result.
Pero en este modo, tan solo siendo, este es el resultado.
Relaxing, abiding in the present moment, wide awake.
Relajándote en el momento presente, completamente despierto.
In this mode, just being, there's no future.
En este modo, tan solo siendo, no hay futuro.
There's only this ever-presenting moment.
Está tan solo este siempre momento presente.
We're never going anywhere.
We've always arrived.
No estamos yendo a ningún sitio.
Estamos siempre llegando.
Relaxing, abiding in the present moment, wide awake.
Relajándote en el momento presente, completamente despierta.
In this mode just being, we're not reacting, we're not responding.
En este modo, tan solo siendo, no estamos reaccionando, no estamos respondiendo.
It's as though we are nobody.
Anonymous.
Relaxing, abiding in the present moment wide awake.
Relajándote en el momento presente completamente despierto.
Achieving nothing, going nowhere, being nobody.
Sin conseguir nada, sin ir a ningún sitio, sin ser nadie.
In this mode we're developing five of the seven factors that lead to liberation.
En este modo estamos desarrollando cinco de los siete factores que nos llevan a la liberación.
There's the awareness of course.
Está la consciencia, por supuesto.
And there's the steadiness of attention.
and the effort needed just to maintain that steadiness.
Está también la firmeza de la atención y el esfuerzo requerido para mantener esa firmeza.
A sense of calmness.
El sentimiento de calma.
The quality of equanimity.
y la cualidad de ecuanimidad.
Not coming from a fixed position, an opinion, very open-minded.
No viene de una opinión fija, la mente muy abierta.
Not coming from aversion,
Fear, greed or preference Open-hearted Open-minded, open-hearted
When this is established, we bring in two further factors, a sense of inquiry and an investigation of the Buddha's teachings.
When this is established, there comes a sense of investigation and the desire to deepen the Buddhist teachings.
But remember this mode is important in ordinary daily life.
To stop like this after a phone call, after a meal, after a job.
Después de un trabajo, después de una comida.
When we stop, we can feel what mood or mental state we are in.
Cuando paramos, podemos sentir en qué estado de ánimo o mental nos encontramos.
We might be happy, we might be feeling stressed.
Podemos estar felices, podemos estar sintiendo estrés.
So just to feel that, just for a moment.
Entonces sentir eso solo por un momento.
And then we can see the next intention.
Entonces podemos ver la siguiente intención.
And we have enough
calmness to decide whether it's something we should do or something we shouldn't do.
Y tenemos suficiente calma para decidir si es algo que debemos hacer o que no debemos hacer.
If it's something we shouldn't do, we should just stay with the feeling of desire until it comes to an end.
Si es algo que no debemos hacer
podemos estar con el sentimiento de deseo hasta que llegue a su fin.
If it's something we should do, then of course we should empower that desire.
Si es algo que debemos hacer, entonces por supuesto debemos empoderar ese deseo.
so our next intention is to sit let's really take our time be aware of every little movement it takes to get the body into a sitting posture
and you can use a little noting word just to keep the attention steady pushing, pulling, lifting, placing
Empujando, trayendo, levantando, bajando Intending to sit Con la intención de sentarte
so make sure you're comfortable the spine in its natural position just lifting up through the top of the head
Elevándose desde la cima de la cabeza.
And spending a few moments relaxing the brow.
Y pasando unos instantes relajando el entrecejo.
Eyes gently closed.
Los ojos.
Relaxing the jaw, lips together, teeth apart.
Shoulders, if there's some tension, give them a good squeeze.
And hands on your lap, whatever is comfortable.
Just acknowledging the posture.
If during the sitting it becomes tense, spend a moment relaxing.
If you find that the body is slumping, then take a moment to lift up that energy.
Draw the attention now to the sensations caused by the breath.
Lleva ahora la atención a las sensaciones causadas por la respiración.
Preferable in the body, but if you're established at the nostrils, that's fine.
Preferablemente en el cuerpo, pero si estableces en las fosas nasales, también está bien.
Just placing the attention
on the gentle sensations caused by the breath Rising, falling
If the mind is wandering, as soon as you wake up note what it's doing.
Si la mente se dispersa, tan pronto como despiertes etiqueta lo que está haciendo.
Planning, planning, worrying, worrying.
Planeando, planeando
preocupación, preocupación.
And then just draw the attention back to the breath.
Y entonces lleva la atención de vuelta a la respiración.
If you're feeling sleepy or tired, lift the spine.
Si te sientes dormido o cansado, eleva la columna vertebral.
and you can open the eyes let the lighting but keep the attention inward resting the attention on the gentle sensations caused by the breath
allowing them to bring silence to the mind calmness to the heart stillness to the body
Rising, falling.
If the mind is wandering, recognize and acknowledge what it's doing.
Si la mente se dispersa, reconoce que se está yendo, lo que está haciendo.
Thinking, thinking, irritation, irritation.
Pensando, pensando.
Irritación, irritación.
And bring the attention gently back to the breath.
Y trae la atención de vuelta de manera suave a la respiración.
Feeling sleepy or tired, lift the spine, open the eyes.
Si estás quedándote dormido o cansada,
Eleva la columna vertebral, abre los ojos.
As we become calmer, perhaps we can get closer to the breath.
Y según vas, estando más calmado, quizás puedas acercarte más a la respiración.
to catch the very beginning of the in-breath and feel it all the way to the very end.
The very beginning of the out-breath, feel it all the way to the very end.
And catch the very beginning of your inhalation and keep it until its very end.
Catch the very beginning of your exhalation
y mantenerlo hasta su mismo fin.
If when you do that you feel you get tense, si cuando haces eso te pones tensa, as it were, sit back within yourself and receive the information.
Siéntate dentro de ti mismo
y recibe esa información.
Rising, falling.
Subiendo, bajando.
Thank you.
the mind is wandering just bring it gently back to the breath acknowledge what it's what's causing it to wander and then bring it back to the breath if the mind is dispersing bring the attention back to the breath recognize what is dispersing it
y trae de vuelta tu atención a la respiración.
Feeling sleepy or tired keep making that effort.
Si estás dormido o cansado sigue haciendo ese esfuerzo.
Once we feel somewhat concentrated, somewhat calm, we can open up to what is causing the mind to wander.
Once you start feeling concentrated, once you start feeling relaxed, you can start opening
tu mente a observar aquello que hace que se disperse If the mind is planning a holiday I let those thoughts go I'm not interested in the story I come back into the body and feel the excitement Si tu mente está planeando un viaje dejo que
se vayan esos pensamientos y llevo la atención al cuerpo para sentir las sensaciones and wait till the excitement begins to fade away y espera a que la excitación comience a disiparse if some worry comes up
Let go of the story, come into the body and feel the anxiety.
And wait for it to pass away.
If there's nothing calling the attention, then come back to the breath.
Si no hay nada llamando tu atención, entonces vuelve a la respiración.
It might be something physical.
Puede ser algo físico.
Some discomfort in the posture, some pain in the knee.
alguna molestia en la postura, algún dolor en la rodilla.
So again, just feel those sensations and if it gets too much, change your posture, do it slowly.
Así es que otra vez, siente esas sensaciones y si es demasiado, cambia tu postura
doing it very slowly.
So, beginning with the breath and then whatever draws the attention within the field of awareness.
So, starting with the breath and then whatever draws your attention in the field of consciousness.
Whatever draws that attention is to be observed, to be felt, to be experienced Lo que llame atención es lo que debes observar, sentir, experimentar Beginning with the breath, rising, falling
Comenzando con la respiración, subiendo, bajando.
becoming more aware of how we are reacting to what we are experiencing how when something is pleasant we're drawn towards it we want to maintain it we want to develop it
¿Cómo si algo nos resulta excitante, queremos mantenerlo, queremos desarrollarlo, nos atrae?
When something is unpleasant, we don't want to feel it, we want to think of something else, we want to push it away.
¿Cómo si algo no nos resulta placentero, no queremos sentirlo,
we want to reject it, we want to eliminate it.
So this sort of desire, which is always manipulating the world in order to make us feel happy and comfortable,
This is the cause of our attachments.
The Buddha says this is the direct cause for our sufferings and unsatisfactoriness.
Is that true for you?
Is this true for you?
becoming more aware of how everything we're experiencing is arising and passing away everything appears only to vanish
Nothing ever repeats itself.
Every breath is similar but not the same.
Can you see anything that you can rely upon?
becoming more aware of how everything I'm experiencing is an object the observer is seeing something
The observer sees a thought or an image The feeler can feel sensations and emotions The experiencer experiences feelings, emotions
and thoughts you can make this distance more obvious to yourself for instance if there is discomfort in the knees
For example, if there is discomfort in the knee, you can say, there, there is discomfort, down there.
So the observer, the feeler is up in the head and the feeling is down in the knee.
¿Y la sensación está abajo en la rodilla?
Same with an emotion.
You can feel it in the body.
Lo mismo con cualquier emoción.
Lo puedes sentir en el cuerpo.
Es un objeto.
Even images you can see in front of you.
Incluso las imágenes las puedes ver en frente de ti.
And thoughts you can be aware of.
y los pensamientos puedes ser consciente de ellos.
So there's a distinction between the observer and the observed.
Así es que hay una distinción entre el que observa y lo observado.
The feeler and the felt.
el que siente y lo sentido and the experiencer and what is being experienced y el experimentador y lo que está siendo experimentado Can the perceiver be the perceived?
Puede el que percibe ser lo percibido
becoming more aware of how everything we're experiencing is arising of its own accord.
Tomando más consciencia de cómo todo lo que surge, lo que va surgiendo, lo va haciendo por sí mismo.
The body offers us
sensations, whether we want it to or not.
El cuerpo nos ofrece sensaciones, tanto si queremos como si no.
Pleasant and unpleasant.
Placenteras y no placenteras.
The heart offers us emotions, pleasant and unpleasant, whether we want it to or not.
The mind is forever thinking and imagining whether we want it to or not.
In this
Vipassana position everything is happening of its own accord.
En toda esta posición de vipassana todo está pasando por sí mismo.
How can they be me?
¿Cómo pueden ellas ser yo?
putting aside all instruction have confidence that this intuitive awareness can understand things directly
Remember that childlike way of looking at things Just observing, feeling, experiencing
sintiendo, experimentando, lo que llame la atención en el campo de la consciencia.
No cambies nada, no hagas nada,
When we come to the end of a sitting, it's good to reflect for a moment.
How diligent were we at bringing ourselves back to the present moment?
If I thought I was diligent, I will congratulate myself.
If I thought I could have been more skillful, I will encourage myself.
No need for self-criticism.
How did we deal with the various physical and mental states that arose?
¿Cómo tratamos con los diversos estados físicos y mentales que surgieron?
Were we experiencing a lot of dullness and lethargy?
¿Estuvimos experimentando mucho abotargamiento y letargia?
Or perhaps agitation?
¿Quizás agitación?
or perhaps an obsessive thinking?
How did we deal with it?
If I thought I was skillful, I will congratulate myself.
If I thought I could have been more skillful, I will encourage myself.
No need for self-criticism.
No hay necesidad para la autocrítica.
Which of those three characteristics of existence was most obvious to us?
¿Cuál de esas tres características de la existencia fueron más obvias para nosotros?
The process of desiring which causes suffering and unsatisfactoriness.
El proceso del deseo que produce sufrimiento e insatisfacción.
How everything is impermanent.
Cómo todo es impermanente.
And how everything is an object, not always under our direct control.
Y cómo todo es un objeto, no siempre bajo nuestro control directo.
Not me, not mine.
No yo, no mío.
And it's good to make a resolution.
Next time I feel sleepy and tired, I will open my eyes immediately.
And don't jump out of the sitting, open the eyes gently, let the light in.
Very good.
Muy bien.